the jurogan experience
yeah have you ever looked into klaus
schwab's like dad no
have you ever heard of new schwabenland
new schwabenland you've never heard a
new schwaben land no have you ever heard
of operation high jump i knew i was
going to love this podcast
no dude operation high jump what does
that mean
okay so
at one point some people like what's
going on with antarctica have you heard
this where they sent admiral bird up
what's going on in north america yeah so
the us government's like something's
going on with antarctica there's some
activity up there we want to find out
what's going on so they send this cat
name admiral byrd up to investigate with
a giant
fleet like just a a fleet to go to go
bank bro you know when was this i think
this was in the uh when was eisenhower
in was it the 50s yeah it was like right
around like
just uh either around world war ii or
right after it and so they sent evra
bird up
to go find out and according to his
journal that they found much later
he
he
basically met with ufos
nazi ufos
what yes this is ufos the nazis the
nazis had a like a flying saucer
had made a deal basically working with
internationals
no it's the greatest story ever bro
it's the greatest story nazis made a
deal with the aliens yes holy [ __ ] for
technology and the deal was they were
going to work together okay
i know this sounds crazy
so basically the aliens go down and and
klaus schwab's dad go down and meet with
eisenhower it's gonna be like we could
we could either do it one way or the
other way we could do it nice or we can
do it the wrong way
and that's where they say eisenhower
made a deal
with
these aliens
that
they could kidnap people and do
experiments but they couldn't just do it
anywhere they had they had specific
places which were our national forest
yeah dude you've never heard of it
[Music]
you're making this sound as if this is
like a story that is commonplace
well for my people it is jamie count me
out here have you heard the story brand
new you've never heard of this
[Laughter]
i am you've never heard of operation
high jump bro i feel like i've heard of
that but i haven't not in this context
this sounds amazing please keep going
and this is where the missing 4-1-1 come
from
the missing information what missing
information no they're missing 4-1-1
what do you mean by that which is all
these people have mysteriously
disappeared in force
and they don't know we're not talking
about the missing 4-1-1 like information
no no no so missing 4-1-1 is a number of
people that have been abducted yeah and
it's all really weird because they all
have like a lot of similar
characteristics german-born like german
background excuse me highly intelligent
and it like i don't know how weird you
want to get bro i want to get weird okay
bro they think like the this might be
some time traveling nazi [ __ ] bro
i know you're gonna think i'm crazy but
it's true dude that's what they believe
and they made a deal
these day folk who who when you say they
believe who are these days the
conspiracy people are they united
no there's a whole different there's a
lot of
warring clans bro
there's a lot of warring clans dude but
that was how deep do you want to go what
is interesting is how advanced the
engineering of the germans was
you know it's really interesting when
you think about car manufacturers like
audi and volkswagen
mercedes it's all at a bmw
bmw didn't bmw make engines for nazi
fighter pilots
i think that's what they first started
they all did well i don't think that's
what bmw did right yeah 100 percent and
then we were cody made hitler a car yeah
hitler had a race car that was never
part of their marketing plan though that
would have been a crazy campaign what
does it say there 1939 bmw 801d
piston piston radial aircraft engine and
national origin is germany
so
that year they made world war ii planes
they made engines for world war ii
planes so this is wild man
i mean ibm was making stuff for these
camps too dude it's crazy
yeah like they had computers talked
about that before yeah right what was
that there's a book
uh what did they do they were making it
was the precursor to actual computers it
was like a uh filing system to keep
track of stuff yeah of who was where and
what into these right i'm remembering
this
and and then you oh yeah man it gets
super weird
but it was called ibm right was it
called something else i think i think it
was ibm yeah the book is called ibm and
the holocaust the strategic
alliance between nazi germany i mean you
ain't [ __ ] around with that title huh
that title is rough
[Laughter]
straight to the point [ __ ] do we do that
did we really do this the strategic
alliance between nazi germany and
america's most popular powerful
corporation expanded
interesting so the area and of
antarctica they went to was new
new schwabenland new schwabenlin do you
think that's why he dresses with the
space 100
so they're all in contact with the
aliens i think well dude i mean
it gets in the i see a lot of people
think it's about power and money we
think it's about it's spiritual war dude
this is these people got all the money
and all the power they got more than
they could ever want i think they want
complete control
but that gets into spirituality not just
complete control but lowering your
vibration and jacking your loose
do you think they're doing that
consciously or do you think they're
doing it like they're chasing the
economics and along the way it actually
becomes a spiritual battle because
everything is a spiritual battle i think
it's done purposely i think they're
they're evil
i think i think they're they're at low
low there's low frequency stuff going on
and they've made deals with people and
things
and
that's why things going on that was very
ambiguous but i understand where you're
going with it okay i mean if you want me
i just don't want to get too weird too
fast bro but fast i'm like we just
opened up we're good
i uh i 100 believe this spiritual war
and that these people are working with
dark entities and that's what this is
all about
let's imagine this
if
there was
like uh
an alien
race that came here from another planet
and gave
just a random group of people
uh
technology yeah gave them an
understanding of things and how to do
things how much of a record do you think
they would keep of that
wouldn't that be something that people
would want to talk about yeah but that
but
that's the beauty of the internet that
we're now able to do that we could never
do that before so you think that's what
the story is about
the the story is about they went there
and they met with aliens and the aliens
gave them information i mean hitler was
really into the occult yeah like he
would send people all over the place he
had a lot of bad ideas yeah a lot of bad
ideas but see the occult has a negative
connotation to it not everything
involved with the occult is negative and
what the occult really means is secret
secret so there's not as much
yeah it's basically mean
it means like it's hidden
i i always associate it with people that
believe in silly [ __ ]
when someone starts talking about the
occult i'm always like um
how do you feel about ghosts you know
how do you feel but like when people
start talking about like dark magic i'm
like
for real you sure i believe in that
there's some energy manipulation but i
don't disbelieve
yeah i don't disbelieve
listen i like i i i don't know what's
going on i just kind of read stuff and
i'm like how does this fit into the
puzzle right how does this fit into the
jigsaw of life
and you start looking around and you
just start going okay man
this is interesting that is interesting
this starts to make sense